مساء الخير اهلا بكم الرابعه من الرياض
السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان يعقد
مباحثات الرسميه مع رئيس الصين في قصر
اليمن
للعلاقات مع العرب
والقياده العربيه توافدون الى الرياض
للمشاركه في القمهتين الخليجيات والعربيه
مع الصين
وزير الاستثمار السعوديه يعلن توقيعها 35
اتفاقيه مع مؤسسات صينيه تشمل قطاعات عده
بينها الطاقه والتعديل
اذا عقد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان جلسه مباحثات مع رئيس الصين في قصر
اليمامه في الرياض واعرب ولي العهد
السعودي في بدء المباحثات عن ترحيبه
بزياره الرئيس الصيني الى الرياض
كذلك ان تعقد قمه بين الرئيس الصيني مع
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز علمان بان زياره جنبينج للمملكه
تاتي تلبيه لدعوه من الملك سلمان بهدف
تعزيز العلاقات التاريخيه والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه المتميزه التي تجمع بين
البلدين
[موسيقى]
متابع في هذا الملف وننتقل الى المركز
الاعلامي للقمه السعوديه الصينيه مع
زملائي في الاحمري اهل النايف تفضل
شكرا خالد يعطيك العافيه اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا نستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه التي
نواكب فيها قمم الرياض التي تاتي في هذه
الزياره الرسميه للرئيس الصيني شيء جميل
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بدعوه من
العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وكما تابعنا في بدايه هذه النشره فقد عقد
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
والرئيس الصيني سجن بنك بعد ظهور اليوم
جلسه مباحثات الرسميه تناولت القضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك زياره الرئيس الصيني
مشاهدينا تاتي كاول لزياره خارجيه له بعد
فوزه في فتره ولايه ثالثه كما ستشهد ثلاثه
قيمه من تحت ظنها الرياض الاولى صينيه
سعوديه والثانيه والثالثه خليجيه وعربيه
صينيه
ولي المزيد ينضم الينا مراسل للعربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي كنت تسمعني او يبدون زميل
عبد المحسن غير جاهز حتى هذه اللحظه مساء
نعود مره اخرى الى عبد المحسن حاله ما
جاهزه هذا المباشر اذا المشاهدين وعقب
وصوله الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اكد
الرئيس الصيني تشيجن بان زياره ستفتح عصرا
جديدا لعلاقات بلاده مع المملكه والعالم
العربي وشدد على مواصله الجهود للارتقاء
بعلاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
الصين والسعوديه الى مستوى اعلى وزياده
المواهمه بين مبادره الحزام والطريق ورؤيه
20 30 اضاف الرئيس الصيني ان الزياره تكرس
كذلك تضامن المجتمع الصيني والعربي لبناء
المستقبل المشترك نحو عصر جديد لافتا الى
اقامه الصين لعلاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله مع اثنتي عشره دوله عربيه
وتحقيقهم انجازات وصفها للايقونيه
والخارقه في شتى المجالات هذا واكد جنبينج
المضيق قدما لبناء علاقات الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الصينيه الخليجيه التي تشهد
تطورا سليما ومستقرا وفقا تعبيره
بانضمه الي هنا في الاستديو
الصحفي الصيني الهام ومرحبا بكم ورئيس
تحرير هند بنده عربيه مرحبا بكم معي في
هذه النافذه التي نبطل فيها تزامنا مع هذه
الزياره وقمم الرياض السيد لي همم تبعث
ربما اليوم هذه التصريحات للرئيس السوري
منذ الامثال ما قال كذلك ووصف هذه العلاقه
مع السعوديه بانها علاقه مهمه وبانها
شراكه همم استراتيجيه لاي مدى هذه العلاقه
اليوم تكرر ستعمق ايضا في هذه الزياره
بالنسبه للصين في الحقيقه هذه الكلمه او
نقول زياره اللقاء بين فخامه الرئيس
الصيني ولي العهد وفي الحقيقه يعني بعد
ذلك كان هناك اللقاء ثنائي بين فخامه
الرئيسين وخادم الحرمين الشريفين ايضا
وهذا يدل على ان هناك احتمال اهتمام
المستوى للجانبين للعلاقات الثنائيه
وخصوصا يعني اذا نجارين المراسم لاستقبال
اليوم
المراسم لاستقبال او ما يسمى بال
الاستقبال في
[موسيقى]
اغسطس الماضي مع رئيس الامريكي فهذا هناك
فرق او فجر واضحه جدا وبلاضافه الى ذلك
يعني العلاقات الثنائيه
بكل معنى الكلمه بحاجه الى جهود المشترك
ليس فقط من جانب واحد من جانب الصيني يعني
هناك حاجه لتعزيز تفاهم مع ثقه المتبادله
السياسيه مع دول الخليجيه وبمثابته
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن الجانب
السعودي ونظرا للركبه او حاجه
لتنويع السياسات الخارجيه وهناك عقبه
لتعزيز التعاون وخصوصا الامن والسياسي مع
الشرك مع الصين ومع اليابان ومع كوريا
الجنو فهذا يعني المصالح المشتركه وايضا
الفوز المشترك من كلا البلددين كيف تترجم
هذه القمه بالنسبه للسعوديه نهجها همم
الاستراتيجيه نهجها في همم ان تتعاطى مع
كل القوه العظمى الدوليه على
مسافه المصالح يعني انا اعتقد ان المصالح
كل فوق كل شيء اولا واخيرا والامر الاخر
يعني الصين هي الشريك وليست حليف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حديث فاذا اخذ لهم
مصطلحات السياسيه كما هي انا اعتقد ان
الصين شريك اقتصادي مهم الصين لديهم
مبادره الحزام الطريق حزام واحد طريق واحد
منذ عام 2013 سعوديه عضو في هذه المبادره
والسعوديه لديه رؤيه 2030 فهنا اكل ثقافي
المصالح همم المشتركه والاستراتيجيه همم
ولكن انا اعتقد يعني يعبر عن ساعات هذه
المره ان همم تحليلات ان الاتجاه شرقا
يعني التخلي غربا خفت في هذه الزياره
ويبدا ان الجميع يعني قد يعني استوعب
بالدرس ان التحال 10 طلع يعني التخلي عن
الغرب الصين لن ترسل البارجات العسكريه
لمنطقه الخليج الصين لن ترسل بارجاتها
العسكريه الى خلجان الشرق الاوسط والمنطقه
الخليجيه بل سترسل استثماراتها واقتصادها
اليوم السعوديه تشكل رقم كبير جدا من
وردات النفط في الصين اكثر من 17% الى 18%
ونعتقد ان هذا رقم مهم المصلحه اقتصاديه
بحته لا علاقه لها بالامن لا علاقه لها
باي شراك عسكريه همم حتى هذه اللحظه قد
تكون في معدات وقد تكون في تقنيات معينه
حتى ولو استذكر البعض واسترجع موضوع صفقه
همم رياح الشرق كان لها ظروف السياسيه همم
المعينه الامر الاخر اذا سمحت لي ايضا
اريد ان يعني نوع على عنواني القمتين في
جده كان هناك مصطلح الامن في في الرياض
كان هناك مصطلح التعاون ولكن العامل
المشترك بينهما التنميه فشاركه المتحده
الامريكيه امنيه عسكريه شراكه مع الصين
همم هي اقتصاديه السياسيه
الى دول الخليج مطعمنا للسعوديه تحديد
الان هناك حزب واحد حاكم في الصين والحزب
الشيوعي لا يمكن ان نقول همم اعتذر لا
اعرف جوال
يعني
صراحه كيف يمكن تحديد هذه المساله ولكن
ايضا هناك حزب واحد شيوعي قوي في الصين
يحكم هناك استقرار في التعامل معه لا يوجد
تبدل كل اربعه وخمس سنوات بتجاذبات قد
تؤثر على اي شراكه وتحالف طيب احنا خليك
تصلح الفني اللي عندك واحنا ننتقل طبعا
اللي همم مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن همم
الحربي وهو موجود في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياضيه التي تستضيف هذه القمه مع عبد
المحسن مرحبا بك معي في هذه النافذه ماذا
على الجدول الرئيس همم الصيني همم اليوم
ماذا تبقى من جدول عمله بعد ان تم
استقباله ايضا اليوم استقبالا رسميا وجلسه
المباحثات نعم ولي العهد السعودي
نعم نايف ينتظر ربما خلال ساعه القادمه ان
يتم الاعلان عن الاتفاقيات والتوقيعها و
ااا كذلك نشر الفيديوهات والصور احيانا
هذا الموضوع من قصر اليمامه الذي اجتمع به
الرئيس الصيني مع ولي العهد السعودي وعقد
جلسات الملاحظات الرسميه قبل اقل من ساعه
من الان يتوقع ان يتم الاعلان عن
تقريبا ما يقارب 20 اتفاقيه وشرعاكه ما
بين الصين والسعوديه مع ان الاعلان عن ذلك
كان مبكرا ولكن قبل الاعلان الرسمي كان
هنالك شركات تم توقيعها يوم الامس على على
اطار ومستوى همم
هذه الصور الان طبعا المباشر على شاشه
العربيه لوصول رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شيعه السوداني الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض للمشاركه في القمه العربيه الصينيه
كنا قد تابعنا منذ اليوم وصول طبعا الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي وبعد ذلك صور
وصول ولي عهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل احمد الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض للمشاركه في هذه
القمم الخليجيه وايضا العربيه الصينيه همم
بتزامنا طبعا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني شيء
جنبي الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض والتي
اتت بدعوه من العهد السعودي الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز اذا هذه صور لحظه وصول رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني الى عاصمه
السعوديه الرياض
للمشاركه في القمه العربيه همم الصينيه
اعود اليك عبد المحسن مره اخرى حتى هذه
اللحظه تبع الاصول الرئيس المصري ولي عهد
الكويت الشيخ مشعل الاحمد والان رئيس
الوزراء العراقي وصل ايضا الى الرياض
ليشارك في القمه العربيه همم الصينيه همم
تتابع لي الرؤساء القاده ايضا واصحاب
السموم المشاركين في هذه القمم ما الذي
تبقى من جدول همم الاعمال ايضا كذلك
والمعلومات المتوفره لديك عبد المحسن
قبل ان اسهم في الحديث عن ذلك نايف كان
ايضا هنالك وصول همم نجيب نقاتل رئيس
وزراء اللبناني وكذلك الرئيس الموريتاني
ولكنهما لم يصل الى الرياض ولكن تفضل
الذهاب الى المدينه المنوره قبل ان ياتي
لرياض ربما خلال ساعات القادمه قد يصل الى
الرياض للمشاركه في القمه بالاضافه لذلك
همم ننتظر وصول اكثر من همم تقريبا
هذه الدول المشاركه سواء كان العربيه او
حتى من خارج المنظومه العربيه المشاركه في
هذه القمه سواء كان اندونيسيا او باكستان
او السنغال او كمبوديا على مستوى القمه
السعوديه الصينيه وهو يوم السعودي خالص
يوم سعودي صيني خالص همم
عقدت جلسه المباحثات قبل قليل كما تحدث
قبل همم سيتم همم
الترقب حول توقيع الاتفاقيات الاكثر من 20
والتي تبلغ همم عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات يتوقع ان يتم بالاعلان عنها
بالاضافه الى ترقب ايضا نايف همم الوثيقه
التي الاعلان عنها وهي وثيقه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه السعوديه الصينيه هذا
الوثيقه لم يتم الاعلان عن تفاصيلها ربما
يتم الاعلان بعد التوقيع بشكل مباشر ولكن
هي وثيقه من الاولى من نوعها وهمم بحسب
الخبراء قد تنقل علاقات الصينيه السعوديه
الى مستوى اخر اليوم مساءا ايضا بعد توقيع
الاتفاقيات وتوقع بان يكون هنالك حفل
العشاء بحضور الرئيس الصيني في همم في
الرياض احتفاء بوصوله وبزيارته للسعوديه
لينتهي بذلك هذا اليوم من القمه السعوديه
همم الصينيه ويتم الاستعداد غدا الى القمه
الاخرى التي سيتم عقدها وهي كما تحدثت
عنها وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه بانها على
مفارقه في تاريخ العلاقات الصينيه
الخليجيه والعربيه على حد سواء لانها تقام
للمره الاولى عن هذا المستوى بهذا الزخم
وبهذه المشاركه الكبيره جدا كل الاطراف
المشاركه سواء كان على مستوى الرصيد ولو
حتى
همم امناء المنظمات الدوليه المشاركه في
هذه القمم نايف
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل ستبقى معنا طبعا في نشراتنا
ونوافذ العربيه طبعا القادمه من هنا من
المركز الاعلامي تابع همم طبعا للقمم
والمتابعه كذلك لقمم الرياضه التي همم
تعقد طبعا تزامنا مع هذه الزياره الرسميه
التي يقوم بها الرئيس الصيني الى العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك يعود الى
ضيوفي مره اخرى واليك سيد عدوان قبل قليل
تتحدث عن شكل التحالف مع الولايات المتحده
وشكل الشراكه مع الصين همم يعني بانها همم
علاقه مختلفه او همم في كل علاقه من هذه
العلاقه هناك كما هو سياسي امني عسكري
هناك ما هو اقتصادي تجاري والسؤال اليوم
هل الغرب هل واشنطن طريقه من هذه الزياره
ولماذا
يجب ان تكون عقلانيه
تحل ضعيفه على السعوديه ولكن لدى الصين في
بحر الجنوبي الكثير من المشاكل والقلق
فيما يتعلق بتايوان فيما يتعلق بالتجديدات
الامريكيه كذلك هناك ولكن في محيط
الولايات المتحده الامريكان يعتقد انها
مستقره المشكله الامريكا الوحيد انها تصدر
المشاكل وهي بعيده عنها ولكن الصين محافظ
بكثير منها المشكله همم تشخيص الواقع انا
اعتقد ان هم لاول مره في تاريخ الشرق
الاوسط والصين يتم افتتاح قائد عسكريه
وكان ذلك في جيبوتي وهذه طبعا كانت لها
اهدافها المتعلقه بالملاحه بحمايه الموانئ
وايضا بالتجاره المستقبليه الصين لديها
شبكه تجاريه مخيفه جدا ولكن مخيفه ايجابيا
في افريقيا
التغلغل الصيني في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي
همم افريقيا تحديدا همم واضح للكل ولا
يستطيع منافستها ابدا حتى ولو دخلت تركيا
في بعض الدول
فلهذا العلاقه مختلفه تماما الشراكه بين
الولايات المتحده
والحلف بانه الولايات المتحده الملكيه
ودول الخليج وتحديين السعوديه منذ عهد
روزفلت الملك عبد العزيز الملك عبد العزيز
ولكن اول لقاء صيني كان عام 1955 ولك ان
تبني على هذه الترتيبات وعلى هذه
التحالفات وايضا كان هناك بعض الخلافات
التي تم حلها فيما يتعلق بتيوان والصين
وكان اعتراف السعوديه همم تايوان ومن ثم
التخلي عن ذلك مستقبلا لصالح حسين كلها
بدات تدريبات ولكن في علاقه السعوديه مع
الولايات المتحده المتحده يعني علاقه تمتد
اكثر من يعني على كل 85 عاما او اكثر همم
يعني يجب وضع الامور في المكان طيب اعود
لك سيد الهام ولكن همم نتابع طبعا هذه همم
الصور همم مباشره همم كذلك ل- وصول رئيس
الله العراقي محمد شيعه سوداني الى
العاصمه السعوديه همم الرياض وفي همم
استقباله كما نشاهد نائب امير منطقه
الرياض الامير محمد بن عبد الرحمن اذا وصل
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني
للمشاركه في هذه القمه القمه العربيه
الصينيه والتي كما ذكرنا سيشار فيها اكثر
من 30 من اصحاب الجلاله والسمو القدر
رؤساء الدول ومنى كذلك ايضا المنظمات
الدوليه كنا قد تابعه على ظهرها اليوم
وصول الرئيس المصري وبعد ذلك ولي عهد
الكويت ايضا بعد القاده وصلوا طبعا الى
المدينه المنوره كما اجار مراسل العربيه
قبل قليل عبد المحسن الحربي منهم رئيس
الوزراء طبعا اللبناني نجيب ميقاتي وكذلك
الرئيس الجيبوتي السيد الهام همم بكين كيف
تنظر الى تحالفات الخليجيه مع الولايات
المتحده هل تتقاطع مع شركتها مع الخليج مع
الاوسط مع طموحاتها في توسيع الشراكه مع
العالم العربي
موجوده
وستكون موجوده خلال السنوات المقبله طويله
لذلك يعني العلاقات الصينيه العربيه او
العلاقات الصينيه الخارجيه
لا تاثيره على العلاقات الخليجيه
الامريكيه في الحقيقه يعني الصين تاسعه
لتعزيز تعاون وتبادل مع هذه الدول
الخارجيه والعربيه ولكن كان مبدا لعدم
تداخل في شؤون الاخرين يعني ما في علاقه
مع العلاقات الخليجيه الامريكيه او سعوديه
الامريكيه ولكن خلاصه القول يعني هناك
اسلوب امريكي او هناك اسلوب عربي غربي
السياسات اتجاه الشرق الاوسط بشكل خاص
تجاه الدول العربيه
فانا نشوف النتائج ماذا حدث في سنوات
الاخيره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
نعم طيب وفي الحقيقه يعني الصين لها نحن
دائما نكون في الصين الاسلوب ذات الخصائص
الصينيه في الحقيقه نعم الان قوه العسكريه
فقط باختصار سيد عطوان هل يمكن للرياضه ان
تنقل اليوم بنفسها عن حاله الاصطفاف حاله
الفارس التي عقبتها الازمه الاوكرانيه
وكذلك حتى التنافس الصيني الامريكي في
تحالفاتها وفي شركاتها في علاقاتها مع
الدول بشكل اساسي والاقتصادي كذالك ذلك
يعني
السعوديه او اي دوله عربيه اخرى لم تختبر
حقيقه في موضوع الاستفاده لا ضد الصين ولا
ضد اي دوله حتى هذه اللحظه يعني كل ما
يحدث هي يعني محاولات اختبارات بسيطه جدا
ولكن الاختبارات الحقيقيه كما حدث في
الحرب العالميه الاولى والثانيه لم يحدث
حتى هذه اللحظه ولكل حتى الحديث وقتها
وانا اعتقد ان كل دوله وقتها ستختار
المعسكر الاقوى الذي يعني تنزوي اليه همم
او اليه وفقه مصالحه وفقه قراءتها الصحيحه
انني عن نفسي يكون دائما في البدايه في
بدايه اي ازمه ومن ثم طيب يجب على اي دوله
ان تتخذ المعسكر الامن الضامن لكما
لاستكمال ما تبقى من الحديث في هذه
النافذه لكن همم الان نتقل الى موقع اخر
من قمم الرياض وزميلان نادين هاني لم
تتحدث باسهاب عن الشق الاقتصادي وهو الشق
طبعا الذي وصف بالمهم في هذه الزياره نديم
مساء الخير اليك
مساء النور نايف لا شك بانه شق الاقتصادي
مهم للغايه نسبه لقوه الصين الاقتصاديه
الصين من القطع من الاقتصادات التي كانت
الاسرع نمونا بالفترات الماضيه لذلك سميت
مجموعه البريكس التي تنتمي اليها الصين
صار في تجمع تسميته بريكس هذا من 2001 جول
من ساعه اقتصاد جول من سكس اطلق تسميه
بريك على مجموعه من الدول اللي هي برازيل
روسيا الهند الصين لانها كانت الاسرع
نمونا واعتبر انه بالالفين ستكون مهيمنه
على الاقتصاد العالمي من بعد ال 2010
انضمت الى افريقيا الجنوبيه لا شك انه هذا
النمو الكبير الذي حققته سنين بالسنوات
الماضيه ولو انه هذه السنه هذا نسبه النمو
النمو بسبب صفر سياسه صفر كوبر او ولكن
جعلتها اقتصاد لديه قدرات بالقطاعات
الصناعيه بقطاعات التكنولوجيا المعلومات
الطاقه النظيفه وكذلك او
جيت ترانزيشن والذكاء الاصطناعي وبالتالي
بالاضافه الى كل ذلك سياسه الصين الخارجيه
تعتمد على الاقتصاد على سبيل المثال
مبادره الطريق والحزام يلهي مبادره تسعى
للاستثمار ب 150 دوله ومؤسسه حول العالم
السعوديه على فكره بنصف الاول من 2022
تلقت استثمارات بخمسه ونصف مليار دولار من
الصين في ظل مبادره الطريق والحزام فاذن
هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى السعوديه هي
اكبر مصدر للنفط الى الصين فبالتالي الصين
تقرا رئيسيه بالنسبه للصادرات النفسيه
السعوديه كذلك السعوديه التي تنوي توزيعها
اقتصادها او تنويعها اقتصادها خارج النفط
همم
المهم بالنسبه لها عقد شركات استراتيجيه
ما بين القطاع الخاص السعودي والقطاع
الخاص الصيني من اجل تبادل المعرفه ونقل
المعرفه بعدد من القطاعات وتقويه عدد من
القطاعات داخل السعوديه للحديث اكثر حول
هذا الموضوع هنا في السجع سيد عمرو بحلوه
رئيس ديوان الاعمال الاساسيه للاستشارات
اهلا وسهلا بك معنا استاذ عمر
هذه القمه السعوديه الصينيه اليوم تؤسس
لشراكه استراتيجيه ما بين البلدين للفترات
القادمه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في الواقع
الصين لها عندها رؤيه 20 49 وتنظر من خلال
هذه الرؤيه الى شركاء استراتيجيين على
مستوى العالم فلما نظرت الى الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا وجدت ان الافضل الاست-
الشركه الاستراتيجيه الامثل والافضل هي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكان هنالك توجه
منذ اكثر من ثلاث عقود ان بدات العلاقات
السعوديه الصينيه في بناء علاقات اقتصاديه
قويه جدا مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
عده نواحي تجاريه استثماريه تبادل معرفه
وبنيه هذه العلاقات
بعطر قويه جدا وعلى مدى بعيد همم تؤثر همم
علاقات استراتيجيه مما يجعل المملكه هي
المركز الاساسي الانطلاق الصين ضمن برنامج
طريق الحرير الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط والى
جنوب شرق اسيا في المملكه بموقع جغرافي
قوي جدا في قلب العالم المملكه احد همم
رواد الطاقه في العالم ان لم يكن الاكبر
في العالم المملكه ايضا لها ثقل سياسي ولا
لها ثقل ايضا اسلامي كن اااه وجود
الحرمين الشريفين في المملكه واحد ونصف
مليار مسلم همم يهتموا باي علاقات
للسعوديه فنظره الصين الى هذا الجانب ايضا
له نظره اقتصاديه بحته همم الصين ايضا
تنظر الى المملكه احد همم مراكز
الثروات المعدنيه الاخرى من ناحيه الدين
الثروه البشريه في تطوير الثروه البشريه
اضافه ايضا الى انها تكون همم بوابه
الافريقيه همم الصين تعتمد ايضا في
مشاريع طريق الحرير الى الوصول الى منطقه
البحر الاحمر والدول المشاطئه للبحر
الاحمر من خلال طريق الحرير والمملكه هي
اكبر دوله تقع على لها حدود البحر الاحمر
تبوك 2000 كم او 2,200 كم فبالتالي كل هذه
المعطيات تجعل من الصين او تجي على الصين
تثق في ان المملكه هي شريك الاستراتيجيه
الامثله لها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
الحزام والطريق قبل ان استكمل الحديث عن
الشق- الاقتصاد البحث همم انا ذكرت كلمه
السياسه الخارجيه للصين لانه نحن بنلاحظ
انه الصين تستخدم القوه الناعمه وبالتالي
الطريق والحزام هو جزء من سياسه الخارجيه
الصينيه فالى اي مدى همم هذا بيفسر ايضا
زياره الرئيس الصيني الى السعوديه
طويل عن العلاقات الصينيه مع الدول
العربيه بنيت اساسها على القوه الناعمه
وهي التجاره التجاره منذ القدم بدات في
قوافل التجاره ويسهل السفن التجاريه سواء
مباشره او غير مباشره
الصينيه الى الى المنطقه المنطقه بشكل عام
نظره همم بالقوه الناعمه مثل تفضلت فيها
ونظراتها ان ت- تريد ان تجد شريك لها
يقودها فيها المنطقه على المدى البعيد اما
عندهم رؤيه 20 49 تتكلم معي على تقريبا
بنتكلم في حدود 39 سنه من الان همم او 29
سنه من الان تت- تتحدث عن همم بعد
استراتيجي لل- للصين في منتهى على
الاقتصاد العالمي فتجد ان هناك قنوات يجب
ان يكون لها رسوم في في المنطقه والمملكه
هي احدى السؤال بعد الى اين تشاهده باللي
حصل دوليا يعني قبل كنا بمرحله
من بعد صار عندنا فولورايزيشن تجاذب قوي
جدا ربما مع الحرب الاوكرانيه الان ولكن
بالفتره الماضيه من حيث انه في تراجع
عليهايمنات الغرب على الاقتصاد العالمي
فالى اي مدى هذا بيلعب دور ايضا بشركات
السياسيه الاقتصاديه عذرا ماليه للدول
اولا لا نغفر ان لا يزال الغرب يملك السوء
للمنتجات السنه فمهما بلغت حجم الانتاج
الصيني يحتاج الغرب لتسويق هذه المنتجات
في اسواق وفي الغرب لا يزال له مكانه له
همم ثقه له ولكن الصين تقوم بعمليه
التوازن في ال- ال- مثل ما تفضلتيشن يعني
بحيث انه لا تكون ايمن
الصدر في هي- هيمن على الاقتصاد العالم
فهيكون في سوقين سوق الشرق وسوق الغرب
واللي يجب ان يكون هنالك توازن بين السوق
الشرق والغرب الصين استطاعت في خلال ثلاثه
عقود ان ترفع عدد 400 مليون همم مواطن في
تحت خط الفقر الى فوق خط الفقر واستطاعت
ان تقلق طبقه ضخمه جدا في الصين فهذه خلقت
سوق موازيه للمنتجات الصينيه والصناعات
الصينيه داخل الصين لتوازي الاسواق
الغربيه ولكن لا يزال امامها طريق طويل
للهيمنه على الاسواق العالميه ولكن لا
ازال تذكر كلمه لرئيس الصيني السابق زيما
لما زار الرياض او زار السعوديه في يمكن
2005 فذاكر ان نتحدى اي بيت في العالم لا
يكون في منتج ميدان شاينا فهذه نظره هذه
نظره بعيده
مقاطع
هذه الصور مشاهدينا الكرام همم
الصور همم طبعا للملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
العاهل السعودي وهو يستقبل الرئيس همم
الصيني همم
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضيه يستقبله
بحضور ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
الملك سلمان
تقع مع الرئيس الصيني اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين اذا
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز يوقع في هذه
الاثناء في هذه الصور التي نتابعها على
شاشه العربيه يوقع مع الرئيس الصيني
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين همم الملك سلمان كما ذكرنا وقع مع
الرئيس الصيني شيء اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين همم
تاتي طبعا من ضمن التي اتفاقيه التي همم
تتوقع ووقعت كذلك تبعنا بالامس اكثر من 35
اتفاقيه وقعت همم بين الجانبين السعودي
والصيني اليوم وهذه الاتفاقيه المهمه التي
وقعها الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع
الرئيس الصيني اتفاقيه الشركه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين كان
امير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد السعودي قد
عقد جلسه مباحثات رسميا مع الرئيس الصيني
همم هذا اليوم كذلك بحضور ولي العهد
السعودي تم منح الرئيس الصيني همم جنبينج
الدكتوره الفخريه من جامعه الملك سعود همم
اذا هذه الصور نتبعه واياكم الان على شاشه
العربيه صور قبل قليل لاستقبال العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
والسلام كذلك همم على الرئيس الصيني شيء
جنبي وكذلك ايضا الوقت المرافق له اذن كما
تعبان كما تابعنا قبل قليل الملك سلمان
يوقع مع الرئيس الصيني همم اتفاقيه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
السعوديه والصين كنا قد تابعنا قبل ذلك
منذ ظهور اليوم الاستقبال الرسمي
للرئيس الصيني من قبل ولي العهد السعودي
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن سلمان
استقبال رسمي وبعد ذلك جلسه مباحثات رسميه
تم توقيفها عدد من الاتفاقيات الثنائيه
بين البلدين ومن الامس كذلك تم توقيع
اتفاقيات بين البلدين وايضا قبل قليل
الولي العهد السعودي همم الرئيس الصيني
شهد مراسم تبادل عدد من الاتفاقيات بين
بلدين وبحضور ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان تم منح الرئيس الصيني
الدكتوره الفخريه من جامعه الملك سعود
وفي الصور التي تتابعناها معكم على شاشه
العربيه الملك سلمان وقع اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين مع
الرئيس الصيني همم
عود مره اخرى هنا الى ضيوفي في الاستوديو
همم الصحه في الصين الهام همم اهلا بكم
مره اخرى معي ورئيس العربيه رضوان الاحمري
اذا اتفاقيه اراك استراتيجيه شامله بين
السعوديه والصين ما الذي تعنيه في دلاله
توقيتها وفي دلاله العلاقه
ومرتكزات العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه يعني
انا اعتقد ان هناك مدينه ضخمه يعني وجدت
من العدم اقتصاديا وهي نيوم والسعوديه
بحاجه الى جميع الشركاء شاهدنا كيف تعامل
الغرب مع الاشتراكات السعوديه في الفتره
الماضيه نوع من الابتزاز نوع من التاخر
نوع من التراجع نوع من العوده بعد كل
الازمه ولكن انا نعتقد ان الصين سيكون
شريك استراتيجي مهم كما اشرت هناك استقرار
السياسي في الصين هناك حزب يعرف ماذا يريد
والسعوديه تعرف ماذا تريد ايضا والصين
تعرف ماذا تريد من السعوديه سيكون لها
انعكاسات اكبر قد ترتفع الحصه الوردات
الصينيه من النفط السعوديه ايضا في هذه
الازمه سواء ازمه الطاقه العالميه او ازمه
الحرب في اكرانيا تبحث عن كل الفرص
الممكنه لسد اي فراغ ممكن عالميا ولي
زياده تواجدها في اسواق شرق اسيا بشكل همم
اكبر اصيل ايضا تريد تستفيد من التنميه
الموجوده في السعوديه من همم
هذه همم بالصور المتبعها الان همم على
شاشه العربيه همم لتوقيع اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين السعوديه والصين
بين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز العاهل
السعودي وكذلك الرئيس الصيني شيء جنبيك
بحضور ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان
ويظهر في الصور الملك سلمان مصافيحا
الرئيس الصيني شيء جنبينج
الوفد كذلك المرافق له اذن همم كما ذكرنا
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وقع اتفاقيه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله مع الصين
بحضور ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان هذه الاتفاقيه تاتي من ضمن التي
اتفاقيات همم التي وقعت اتفاقيه ايضا
ستتوقع في همم خضم هذه ازياء وفي اثناء
هذه الزياره كذلك الامير محمد بن سلمان
منح الدكتوره الفخريه بحضوره منحت للرئيس
الصيني همم الجيش والذي طبعا او شيء
جنبينج عفوا الذي ياتي الى الرياض في هذه
الزياره الرسميه لمده ثلاثه ايام لحضور
ثلاث قمم همم السعوديه صينيه خليجيه عربيه
همم صينيه طبعا اذا نعيد التذكير بهذه
الصور الان ل همم الاتفاقيه التي وقعت بين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز والرئيس الصيني
في جنبينج اذا وهنا صور استقبال العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
للرئيس الصيني الذي وصل الى العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضيه يوم امس مع وفد صينيين
همم ايضا الى السعوديه بدعوه من الملك
سلمان طبعا لحضور همم ثلاث قمم همم وصفت
بانها هامه ودقيقه في توقيتها وفي
دلالاتها ايضا ااا كذلك وفي ظرفها حتى
ايضا الزمني اذا هذه الصور لاستقبال
الرئيس الصيني شيء جنبينج في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض من الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز الذي وقع مع الرئيس الصيني هذه
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه الشركه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين البلدين السيد هذه الاتفاقيه
ما الذي ستعنيه لمستقبل البلدين ما بعد
توقيعه
في الحقيقه يعني في عام 2016 كان هناك
اتفاقيه ايضا اتفاقيه لتاسيس علاقات
الشراكه استراتيجيه بين جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه ومن مملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
هذه الاتفاقيه كان في زياره فخامه الرئيس
الصيني في الى المملكه
2016 الان اتفاقيه جديده تعتبر خطوه جديده
عزيزه لايكات بين البلدين نحن نعرف يعني
بنسبه من بين دول العربيه فدول الخليج
تتمتع باهميه البالخه ومن بين دول
الخليجيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تتمتع باهميه خاصه ومن الممكن ان اقول
الان في العصر الحالي اا ال- العلاقات
السعوديه سينيه او صينيه سعوديه في افضل
حال منذ تاسيس العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين
واليوم يعني هناك التصريح من قبل كثيرا من
المحللين الصينيين بان العلاقات الصينيه
سعوديه الان في فتره الذهبيه ولذلك يعني
هذه الاتفاقيه وايضا المنح الفخامه الرئيس
الصيني دكتور الفخري من جامعه الملك سعود
همم يعكس على اهتمام الجانب السعودي
بالعلاقات الثنائيه ومن جانب الثاني يعني
كما ذكر همم استاذ الفاضل همم بان
العلاقات الثنائيه يعني تعتمد على عقبه
مشترك بين البلدين وخاصه يعني انا اوافق
على ضيف الفاضل بان هناك يعني قلق
من من الجانب الدول الخارجيه ازاء
لتحديدات الامنيه ولكن في الحقيقه يعني
النظره لتجريبات ممكن ان نقول الفاشله من
قبل الدول الغربيه وبما ثابتها الولايات
المتحده فالان الصين لديها دوره متميز في
القضايا للشرق الاوسط مهما كانت في قضيه
وايضا في قضيه فلسطين والقضايا الاخرى
لذلك يعني انا ارى ان هناك دور الايجابي
جدا
وهناك دور مهم ايضا لللجنه السعوديه
الصينيه المشتركه سيد همم رفيعه المستوى
التي راسها من الجانب السعودي ولي العهد
من الجانب الصيني ايضا رئيس مجلس الدوله
ما الذي اضافته هذه اللجنه لمستوى
للعلاقات بين البلدين لتوسيع
ذات الاقتصاد التجاره التنسيق ايضا حتى
السياسي والامني بين البلدان يعني جزء
منها قد يكون ما هو يعلم في الاخبار يعني
ولكن اعتقد لو شاهد تدريجيا همم باخرها
حتى وجود شركه علي بابا في السعوديه يعني
احد اكبر شركات صينيه ارتفاع الواردات
تدريجيا ووصلت بعد عام 2020
حتى هذه اللحظه للاعلى في تاريخ العلاقه
بين السعوديه والصيف من ناحيه الصادرات
النفطيه الى الصين انا اعتقد كل هذه عبر
هذه اللجان المشتركه يعني هناك ما يعرف
هناك ما لا يعرف على مستوى الامني
والعسكري والاقتصادي ولكن كما شرحت انا
اعتقد ان اكثرها في جانبها هي متعلقه
بالاقتصاد متعلقه بالتنميه المتعلقه
بتعزيز الصادرات النفطيه السعوديه الى
الصين ومتعلقه ايضا بتوطينا التقنيه
السعوديه عبر محتوى محل سعودي ولكن بخبرات
همم الصينيه وهذا ما يحدث الان في التعاون
سواء في مجال الامن السيبراني وانا اعتقد
ان الصين لديها خبره واسعه سواء تصدر
الهجمات او حتى في همم نقل هذه الخبرات
الى همم
الى مثل السعوديه التي لديها اهتمام كبير
جدا في مجال الامن السبراني والمعلومات
هذه الفتره ولكن كما قال يعني اسمح لي
نعلق على مقاله السيد همم الهاملي حينما
قال ان التجارب الفاشله للامن او للغرب في
في موضوع الامن في الخليج يعني قبل ايام
ثلاثه ديسمبر الماضي للصول الخامس
الامريكي اعلن ضبط شحنه من الاسلحه
والمتفجرات المتجهه من ايران الى اليمن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تستطيع
الانسحاب من الخليج ولا تريد الانسحاب من
الخليج وهي ولكن هي منارات همم دائما
وممله اصبحت حتى للجانب السعودي او اي
جانب اخر يدخل في علاقه
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن يعني نكون منطقيين
الصين لن تكون بدي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الصين لا يوجد لديها حامل
الطائرات في العالم تكفي الصين لا يوجد
لديها سيطره على القواعد العسكريه في
العالم او منافذ البحريه ولهذا يعني اعتقد
لو قارن همم نقول لا تصل الصين الى 10 او
15% من القوه العسكريه البحريه الامريكيه
المنتشره في انحاء العالم فلا يمكن ان
تكون بدينه وهذا سؤال مهم سيد الهام انه
الى اي مدى الصين قادره ان تكون
نموذجا يعني موازي للنموذج الديمقراطي
الليبرالي الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط في
ايضا علاقته مع العالم العربي
والسؤال المهم جدا لماذا لازم ان تكون
الصين بديل للولايات المتحده طبعا قبل ان
تجيب استاذنك فقط بالمقاطعه تفضل السعوديه
والصين اذن مشاهدينا في هذه الاخبار
العاجله توقعيها على مذكره التعاون لتعليم
اللغه الصينيه واقعا كذلك على اتفاقيه
للتعاون والمساعده القضائيه في المسائل
المدنيه
والتجاريه توقيعان كذلك على مذكرهم في
مجال الطاقه الهيدروجينيه كما نشاهد الان
توقع كذلك على همم توقعان على مذكره تفاهم
في مجال التشريع اسمها المباشر اذا جمله
من همم
مذكره التفاهم الموقعه بين البلدين
يتابعها الان على شاشه العربيه تباعا في
شريط الاخبار العاجله اذا السعوديه توقع
العديد من المذكرات مذكرات التعاون
التفاهم كذلك
التعاون طبعا في مجال الاسكان والتعاون
كذلك لتعليم اللغه الصينيه السعوديه
والصين ايضا وقعت وقعت على مذكره تفاهم في
مجال تشجيع الاستثمار همم المباشر وقعتا
كذلك على اتفاقيه للتعاون والمساعده
القضائيه في المسائل المدنيه التجاريه
وكذلك في مجال الطاقه الهيدروجينيه همم
كذلك السعوديه والصين توقعان على خطه
المواهمه بين رؤيه المملكه 2030
ومبادره الحزام والطريق سبقها قبل ذلك
الاتفاقيه ربما الاهم بين كل هذه
الاتفاقيات وهي توقيع الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز الرئيس الصيني همم شيء جنبينج
اتفاقيه الشركه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين اعود لك سيد همم الهام مره اخرى
همم
اذا وفي تفصيل هنا قبل ان اعود اليك سيد
الهامي اذا سمحت لملك سلمان استعرض فيه
لقائه مع الرئيس الصيني علاقات الصداقه
التاريخيه همم بين همم البلدين ووقع بعد
ذلك همم اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
السعوديه
والصين ثلاثه جمله من مذكره التفاهم
التعاون ايضا بين البلدين في مجالات
الطاقه والاسكان والتعليم
وهمم وايضا الاستثمار التشجيع الاستثمار
المباشر كنت قد سالت قبل قليل سيد الهام
هل يمكن ان تكون الصين قادره على ان تكون
نموذج موازيا للنموذج همم الامريكي في
المنطقه في الشرق الاوسط وفي العالم
العربي
حقيقه يعني كما لحسنا في صور قبل قليل
في كل الاتفاقيه مرتبطه بالتنميه مرتبطه
بالتعاون وفي الحقيقه يعني
بالنسبه لموضوع انسحاب القوات الامريكيه
من دول الخليج او من الشرق الاوسط هذا ما
يهم الصيني بالتعاون مع ال اا الدول
المعانيه بخصوص التنميه والتعاون في مجال
مهما كان نتائج الساتيا وسياسيه وحتى
العسكريا يعني اذا نرجع الى بدايه تاسيس
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين مملكه العربيه
السعوديه هنا هناك موضوع معروف مهم جدا
وبلاضافه الى ذلك يعني الامن ليس معناه
نشر الجنود في جميع الدول العالم وفي
الحقيقه يعني اذا نرجع ما قبل همم 50 سنه
او 60 سنه يعني الموضوع همم
قضيه الخليج او حتى الموضوع في ايران
السبب الجدري ليس من الدول الخليج او ليس
تران نفسها ولكن ان الموضوع رئيسي مرتبطه
بالسياسه الولايات المتحده في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط لذلك يعني لا نقول بديل يعني الصين
بديل للولايات المتحده في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وحتى بالعالم باكمله ولكن هناك
اسلوب خاصه من الجانب الصيني لتنميه مع
مبادرتين
الامن العالمي ومبادرات التنميه العالميه
وهذا من فقمه الرئيس الصيني خلال سنه
الماضيه وهذا يعني تلقى بالترحيب واسع من
قبل الدول العربيه بخصوص المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
التي وقعت قبل قليل همم كنا قد تابعناها
في شريط العاجل يعني في مجالات مختلفه في
مجالات التعليم في مجله الاسكان في مجالات
الاستثمار يعني في اكثر من مجال الى ماذا
تدلل هذه الاتفاقيات وشكل هذه الاتفاقيات
تنوعها ايضا كذلك بالنسبه للسعوديه التي
تعيش هي الاخرى حاله من التحول الاقتصادي
الكبير منذ الاعلان عن رؤيه 2030 يعني
اليوم يعني لا يوجد يومه ويومين لو تشاهد
ارتفاع تضخم في دوله ما يو- ليله البارحه
اعلن عن ميزانيه السعوديه فيها فائض 4.3
تقريبا مليار دولار السعوديه تريد استثمار
هذه الاموال في توطين تقنيتها في توطين
الصناعاتها لو لاحظت في جميع الاخبار
العاجله التي وردت قبل قليل على
الاتفاقيات المتوقعه الجميع على علاقه
بالتنميه والاقتصاد بشكل مباشر وكما قلت
يعني قبل حتى هذه الاعلان انها لها علاقه
بنقل خبرات الصينيه الى السعوديه
بالاستفاده من الش- يعني الخبرات سواء في
مجال الاسكان في مجال البناء السريع في
مجال الامن الاستمراني في مجال حتى الطاقه
البديله والنظيفه وهذا امر هو هجمت عليه
الصين وهو هجمت عليه السعوديه في قمه
المناخ 26 التي اقيمت في اسكتلندا
فهذه الشراكه موجوده ولكنها كما قلت ستبقى
في اطار معين الموضوع الامن او الموضوع
والعسكري انا اعرف ماذا يقصد السيد الهام
وهو انه اما تبادل معلومات يا اخري ولكن
اتحدث عن الحمايه والامن يجب ان يعترف
الجميع بقدوده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الصين لعب الدور ما هو ما اعتذر ان كان
عطلت الصين لعب الدول ما هم قبل سنوات في
معلومات تم تسريبها بانها لاعب الدوري
الوساطه ما بين السعوديه وايران لتهدئه
الخلاف فلهذا قد تلعب ايضا الصين دور
الوسيط المسالمه او الباحث عن السلامه
والدافع عن السلامه في المنطقه همم بدلا
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واخيرا
اختلف معك حينما قلت ان ما يحدث من خلاف
بين السعوديه وايران او سلوك ايران في
المنطقه بسبب السياسات المتناقضه يعني هذا
همم تكرر كثيرا في الفتره الماضيه من كثير
من المحلين وكانه تبرير لايران بانها دوله
مسلمه ولكن تناقضات دوله ارهابيه راعيه
للارهاب ولكنها تستفيد من تناقضات واشنطن
في التمدد همم اكثر سيد الهم هل همم تترك
الصين هذا القلق الذي ربما عبر عنه السيد
ع والاحمر قبل قليل قلق دول الخليج من
بالخطر الايراني من خطر همم تسليح اذرعه
في المنطقه نشر الميليشيات في المنطقه
التدخل في الشؤون الخارج الداخليه
للدول الخليجيه والدول العربيه ايضا كذلك
وبان المواقف الصينيه لا تتناغم ربما مع
مواقف همم دول الخليج على الاقل نعم في
بصراحه يعني الصين تتفاهم على
مواقف او قلعه خليجيه او الدول العربيه
وفي نفس الوقت ايضا الصين تتفاهم على
قال لك من جانب الايران وخصوصا يعني ايران
دوله كانت يعني تتعارض العقوبات لمده
سنوات طويله وهذا يعني ايران تعاني من هذه
العقوبات وهذا يعرف عن تنميه الاقتصاديه
وتحسين المعيشه شعب في الحقيقه يعني همم
الصين دائما كما ذكر همم استاذ الفاضل همم
الصين تلعب بالدورا متسالا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط يعني ااا حتى بدون حاملات طيران
حتى بدون النشره القواعد العسكريه ففي
الحقيقه يعني الان مع ال ال كيف نقول
تقويه
الاقتصاديه وحتى قوه العسكريه الان هناك
همم السلطه الكلام من جانب الصين في جميع
مناطق العالم بما فيها الشرق الاوسط وخاصه
يعني مع النفوذ الصيني على كل من ايران
وايضا على الدول العربيه اعتقد الصين ترعب
دورا مختلفه عن الولايات المتحده او دول
الغربيه ولكن هذا دور ايضا مفيد بنسبه
لتعزيز او الحفاظ على الاستقرار عون اقول
تحقيق الاستقرار والسلام في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط الخليج بالتحديد هذه الزياره هذه
القمم ايضا بالنسبه للدول الخليج بالنسبه
لي ايضا ال- ال- العالم العربي بالنسبه
السعوديه هي تستضيف دوله دائمه العضويه في
مجلس الا مهمه على مستوى السياسي على
مستوى الاقتصاد كيف يمكن استثمار الصين في
في هذه النقطه تحديدا انا اعتقد انه يعني
الصين نحن نحتاج الصين دول الخليج تحتاج
الصين العالم العربي يحتاج الصين في كثير
من الامور مرتبطه تحديد البلوغ المتحده
وفي تحديد حشد الاصوات او محاوله توحيد
الصين حتى عن عدم همم استخدام حق النقظه
واحيانا حتى بالحياد لانه هناك دول قد
تغضبها الصين لانها حريفه معها في حالنا
اتخذت قرار ردها كيران يعني الصين تحاول
ايضا ان تستفيد من همم الازمه في ايران
بالاستثمار في الاقتصاد الايراني بعد رفع
الحظر وهذا امر لا يمكن يعني ان يحجب عن
احد في الازمه في لبنان مثلا الصين دخلت
باستثمارات قويه فالصين تريد الاستثمار
الاقتصادي تريد ان يعني تقوي شبكتها
الاقتصاديه اليوم اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحتل العالم
بشكل نواخر او تسيطر على منافذ العالم
البحريه عبر الباريات وحملت الطائرات انا
اعتقد ان الصين استطاع التطويق دعنا نقول
70 ل 80 بالمئه من العالم بتجارتها يعني
نفودها الاقتصادي وبتكتيكها المعروف
التمويل ومن ثم الدفع الاخر وهو الذي يعني
اتهم لبعض الصين في بني محاوله يعني تطويق
الدول او محاوله حتى يعني تضع لها نفوذ لا
تستطيع الدوله اخراج نفسها منه الا بتسديد
هذه المستحقات على عقود طويله وحدث مثلا
في مشروع بعض مشاريع سواء في
السودان او في
لبنان ولكن نحن نحتاج الصين الصين تحتاج
الى دول الخليج الصيل لديها مشروع الحزام
الطريق الذي يغطي 68 دوله عدد الدول التي
قد تحضر على اعتقد يعني المؤكد حضورها 14
دوله حتى هذه اللحظه هذه القمم يعني في
هذه القمم الثلاثه تتحدث عن 14 يعني
تقريبا 20% من ال 68 الدوله التي تغطيها
الحزام الطريق موجوده في هذه القمه فستسهل
الكثير والقادم اجمل
الدول الخليجيه والعربيه من الصين الصين
ماذا تحتاج من هذه الدول
اول شيء يعني الصين تحتاج الى دعم سياسي
ودعم ال- ال- امني للحفاظ على الانستغرام
في هذه المنطقه لان العلاقات
مثلا في القضايا الاقليميه وتوليه مثلا في
مثل ما ذكرت ذكر طيف الفاضل يعني في الامم
المتحده وفي اللي بعد القضايا مثلا في همم
الحقوق الانسان لان كل الدوله لديها قيم
خاصه وكل دوله لديها
علاقاته وتقاليدها خاصه لذلك يعني الصين
تتمتع بال- قيم المشتركه مع الدول العربيه
وبمثابتها الدول الخليجيه وفي الحقيقه
يعني هناك احترام متبادل وهناك كيا مشترك
بين الاجانبين لذلك يعني
لو وافق يعني نهائيا بان كل شيء يعتمد على
المصالح وخصوصا على المصالحه تجاريه بين
الاصدقاء بين الاصدقاء هناك شيء مختلف
تماما يعني فوق المسلحه فوق الفلوس فوق
الاموال وهذا يعني ما نتمنى لها بين الصين
ودول العربيه وبين الصين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الاحترام ايضا كما ذكرها الرئيس الصيني
ايضا في همم مقاله هذا يوم كنت قراته
السيد عدوان تبعت
بعد ما تضمنه ايضا همم كذلك يرغب بتضامن
تعاون لبناء مجتمع صيني عربي لمستقبل
مشترك نحو العصر الجديد كذلك قلبي ان
الصين همم لا تتدخل في شؤون الدول او
تحاول ان تفرض عليها بعض القيم بعض
المبادئ كيف تعلم يعني اريد ان اعلق على
ما قال السيد الهام اولا يعني بدون وجود
مصالح مشتركه بدون وجود مصلحه لان ياتي
الرئيس الصيني ويطير كل هذه الساعات
للحضور للسعوديه ولي ال- ال- همم الالتقاء
بها هؤلاء القاده والعقد شراكه سعوديه
صينيه المصلحه فوق كل شيء المصلحيه ما
تدفع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم
الى العوده الى السعوديه بعد التهديد
بنفها وبيجعلها دوله فلا يمكن ابدا التخلي
عن كلمه المصالح المصالح فوق فوق الاخوه
في السياسه وفوق الجيره في السياسه وفوق
كل شيء فاذا اعترفنا بهذا الامر اعترافنا
ان المصالح كل شيء او ان تصبح السياسه
يعني عباره عن جمعيه خيريه والعلاقات بين
الدول
امر بناء على انني احبك وتحبني ودعنا يعني
اختلف معك قليلا فيها لان همم يعني نقطه
غير منطقيه تماما نقول ان لا يوجد شيء
اسمه المصلحه وانما الاخوه والشراكه
الشراكه مبنيه على مصلحه لو لم يوجد الصين
خبرات في الاسكان ولو لم يجد خبرات في
البناء السريع ولا في انشاءات البنيه
التحتيه ولا في يعني الطاقه البديله الان
والنظيفه ولا في الامن السيبراني لما تم
التعاون معها ولو لم تكن هي القوه
الاقتصاديه الاقوى لم تعد تنين نائم كما
يقول الناس اليوم الصين ليست للناس بل
تنين يلتهم همم كثير من المرجح ان يصبح
كثير في العالم
الاسواق النائمه التي كانت الولايات
المتحده عنها اصبحت الصين اليوم يعني
تسيطر على هذه الاسواق فيعني ثم
انتما والسيد الهام في الوقت الذي توقع
فيه الكثير من الاتفاقيات بين السعوديه
نعم نعم
طبعا نعيد لانه نذكر فقط همم هذه الحواجب
بشكل سريع الملك سلمان استعرض مع الرئيس
الصيني بحضور ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان سبل تعزيز العلاقات
الثنائيه بشتى المجالات السعوديه والصين
وقعتها على همم على طبعا وثيقه همم
وثيقه او مذكره التعاون التعليم اللغه
الصينيه مذكره التفاعل مجال تشجيع
الاستثمار المباشر
وكذلك الاتفاقيه الاكبر وهي اتفاقيه
الشركه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلديه
شكرا لسيد عدوان الاحمري رئيس التحريده
عربيه السيد الهام علي ابن الصحفيين شكرا
لكم
[تصفيق]